This one's a little trickier.
First, I have to make the intermediate step of realizing,
hey, I know what the tangent of α is.
The reason I know this is because I know what the opposite side is. It's 4.
I know what the adjacent side is--7.
I know tangent relates those two,
so I can say tangent of this angle α--I don't even know what that is yet,
but I know it's equal to 4/7.
I know that it's possible to go back and forth between angles and these ratios.
I can type into Google "arctan 4/7 in degrees."
I don't want my answer is radians. The answer is 29.74 degrees.
Now, this was a lot we just went over.
It's one thing to be doing this with tables,
but now we've introduced this new notation,
this new word arc tangent, arc sine, arc cosine.
If you're feeling comfortable with all this, you should move on.
But if you're still a little shaky on sines and arctangents,
go back and rewatch whatever is helpful to you.
If you still have any questions after that,
be sure to visit the forums, and there will be plenty of people,
myself included, who are there to help.